We should tell him the truth
welcome back everyone
this is my doctor strange 2 video all about the
secret god tier villain that's been hiding in
the poster for the movie in all the trailers
it confirms my theory about scarlet witch not
being the real villain of the film or even the
multiverse illuminati team for that matter and
this character has been staring us in the face
for the past few weeks since that last new trailer
was released some of you have probably realized
what i'm talking about and no i'm not talking
about deadpool because there have been a bunch
of deadpool memes any tips on uh getting into the
mcu there cork it would be funny if deadpool does
turn up during the film but the character that
i'm talking about is completely different so if
you're new to the channel i'm doing a giveaway
for the spider-man no way home blu-rays they
just announced all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your theory about the
villain of doctor strange 2 in the comments below
although after you watch this video your theory
about who the real villain is might change so the
big thing first we have to address is how they're
misdirecting us trying to fake us out make us
think that scarlet witch or a version of her is
the actual villain of the film but i don't think
that's true i think it's a complete misdirect
in both of the two new trailers they released
at the super bowl a couple weeks ago even though
both trailers have different footage the way
that marvel edited them they really want us to
think that the two different versions of scarlet
witch are the villains of the movie rmcu scarlet
witch in her new costume attacking doctor strange
and then carmartash to force america chavez to
help her travel to this other universe version of
westview with her home from one division so that
she can find billy and tommy or a version of billy
and tommy they kind of teased that during the one
division post-credits scene like she heard
their voices crying out from the multiverse
then we have this other universe version
of scarlet witch that looks a little bit
different who's ripping through the illuminati
base this maria rambo captain marvel variant
r.i.p and those other superior iron man iron
legion robots that look kind of like ultron
but my early theory is this is kind of a misdirect
kevin feige loves scarlet witch's character loves
wanda loves elizabeth olsen says that she's going
to be a really big character in the future marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5. and as cool as it is to
see her go ham on the multiverse both versions
of her he's not going to throw her under the bus
part of the story of this multiverse illuminati
team is that they kind of view themselves as the
end-all be-all arbiters of order in the multiverse
protecting the sanctity of reality like that
version of baron mordo arrests doctor strange
and says in the trailer your crimes against
reality will not go unpunished thank you very
much for helping out with that spider-man back
during spider-man no way home just stop talking
they view it as their job to stop doctor strange
america chavez both versions of scarlet witch
from messing with the multiverse even more that's
the whole reason why they would arrest all these
characters and put them in these cells so for
part of the movie they're kind of antagonists
like they'll fight the mains in the movie just
a little but they're not straight up villains
it's like captain america civil war iron
man and captain america were not villains
they were just antagonists for each other
briefly because of their opposing views
so who then is the actual main villain of doctor
strange too there has to be somebody that you can
point to at some point in the film and say no they
are the true villain of this situation this will
also get into the true villain of juan division
and what the producers said that they were going
for even if it wasn't clear who the actual villain
was during one division it was not scarlet witch
even though she did hold that whole town hostage
for a week but we finally got some confirmation
from the doctor strange 2 poster the brand new one
that they released with the trailer a couple weeks
ago the poster with a thousand tiny easter eggs
hidden in all the shards of the window panes here
these are the broken pieces of that main window in
the sanctum with the symbol of the vashanti on it
and there are actually two cool new details that
we spotted in this i'll talk about the secret
villain first zoom in enhance on this part right
here this is your secret villain of the movie
and that gruesome looking face definitely makes
him seem like a villain the person who would be
responsible for manipulating mcu scarlet
witch pushing her to use her chaos magic
and do all these terrible things to try and find a
version of billy and tommy we all thought somebody
would be manipulating scarlet wish to do all these
terrible things turns out that's kind of true and
it's not who you think it is so a lot of longtime
comic book fans were posting in my feed about this
thinking that this was meant to be c'thon the god
of chaos in back during the one division episodes
that was my early theory too because of the way
they were using the dark hold there are a couple
ways to pronounce his name but in the comics he's
the elder god who created the dark hole that's
why everybody was thinking of catholine when they
saw the darkhold during the trailer you see doctor
strange using the dark hole to perform a forbidden
spell that involves the multiverse that's what
he's doing here c'thon is also the person who
gave scarlet witch her chaos magic powers in the
comics when she was born but here's the thing this
person on the poster is not meant to be catholic
it's actually D'Spayre in confirmation comes from
the marvel toys that they've been releasing for
the movie with all the characters for the legends
line it's funny that somehow it's always the toys
where you get all these details if you look at
D'Spayre's face in the toy art everyone's toy art
looks a little bit less hardcore than they do in
the actual movie because these are supposed to be
for little kids and they don't actually want to
give little kids nightmares but in the official
description for the character that they're
billing for the mcu they call mcu D'Spayre the
embodiment of all fear and D'Spayre does it not
look like scarlet witch has been full of D'Spayre
for pretty much her entire run of the mcu and all
the different movies it just got way worse during
wandavision the producers of wandavision said that
the real villain of the series was actually meant
to be her grief her D'Spayre and that was what
pushed her to do everything that she did they did
a version of the character during marvel's cloak
and dagger tv series but i'm considering that like
a completely different spin on the character than
what they're doing in the mcu clearly visually
obviously mcu D'Spayre looks very different
this version of D'Spayre in doctor strange 2
is way more god-tier in the comics he's meant to
be trapped in this nexus of all realities and he
comes from this group of dark dimensions called
the archipelago of anguish in this trailer scene
where you see america chavez doctor strange and
the christine palmer variant from the illuminati
team open this door it seems like they're in
the basement of this illuminati base they open
this door to what seems like a special nexus it
kind of seems like it might be the nexus of all
reality so pull out all your wandavision nexus
memes and it seems like they're using D'Spayre the
character in the movie in the mcu in the same way
that they use the dweller in darkness during the
shangxi movie they made you think that for most of
the shangshi movie wen wu was the main antagonist
like they want you to think that scarlet witch
in the trailers is the antagonist during doctor
strange too but really when wu was just being
ghastly manipulated by the dweller in darkness who
was using its power to deceive him into releasing
it the character D'Spayre feeds off of negative
emotions scarlet witch seems like she's been
suffering from as many negative emotions as you
could possibly think of since one division i mean
even before that going back in all the mcu movies
in the trailer doctor strange talks about
waking up having this same nightmare about this
multiverse catastrophe every single night D'Spayre
would also be the character manipulating him to
have those nightmares so that he could feed off
of his negative emotions while he's having them
in the comics he's also known for corrupting good
sorcerers and i think that's the whole idea with
scarlet witch is that she does have this crazy
chaos magic power that makes her super op it's not
meant to be good it's not meant to be evil issues
that forces outside of her have been pushing her
to do these crazy things with it now it seems
like they're trying to tell us through all these
easter eggs that that force is the character
D'Spayre so my early theory is that D'Spayre is
like the new version of dweller in darkness for
doctor strange 2 and scarlet witch tricking her
into breaking the multiverse open wide so that
he can escape and that might have something to
do with this big professor x scene during the
trailer when they haul dr strange in professor
x says we should tell him the truth they might
be about to tell him what's really going on with
D'Spayre like no no no we have to stop scarlet
witch because she's really being manipulated
the true threat to all of reality is this D'Spayre
character and we have to stop her or else she's
going to accidentally release him that was the
conversation that sheng xi had with his father wen
wu at the end no father you've not been listening
to your dead wife this whole time she's not on the
other side of that barrier is this giant villain
that's been manipulating you this whole time
as for that other really cool god tier easter
egg in the poster zoom and enhance on this part
here this book of magic is not the darkhold it's
actually the book of the vashanti the symbol on
all the sanctums in the symbol of the giant
enchantment that all the sanctums form around the
mcu earth protecting it and this main mcu reality
from other dimensions like dormammu in the dark
dimension in the comics the vishanti are this trio
of godlike beings who give doctor strange all of
his magical power to weave spells they explain
it a little bit differently in the mcu where he
gets his energy from to weave spells in the movies
they haven't really shown the vashanti themselves
on screen the actual characters but they're a trio
of elder gods from different pantheons around the
universe it's hoggoth oshtur and agamotto and
that name will sound familiar because doctor
strange wears the eye of agamotto around his
neck that amulet so the vashanti would be like
enemies of the evil elder gods the fearlords
like to spare villains from other dimensions
like dormammu if they're featuring the book of
the vishanti this prominently in the poster it
sounds like they'll at least reference them during
the movie if we're lucky they might actually have
a cameo scene doctor strange doesn't worship the
vashanti like gods he just forms a pact with them
and there have been times in the comics where
something happens to sever their bond and he has
to go seek magical power from some other source
scarlet witch gets her power from chaos magic so
they might also tie D'Spayre to mcu chaos magic
as well i know there are a lot of theories about
shuma gorath or gargantos whatever you want to
call him here they're calling him gargantos in
the movie but really he's meant to be a version
of shuma gorath there was just a copyright ip
problem that marvel has with using the shuma
gorath's name he's another really huge villain
but because of the way they're using him in the
trailer so prominently early on this also might
be a misdirect and he probably isn't going to be
the main villain of the film usually when it comes
to big twists marvel tends to hide those really
subtly in the background he moves right there
coincidence i think not so everybody post all your
theories in the comments below do you think that
D'Spayre is the one that's actually manipulating
scarlet witch to do all these crazy things
we're getting a new morbius trailer with more
andrew garfield toby mcguire easter eggs really
soon so make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that i'll post it as soon as
they release it everyone click here to learn about
superior iron man during the doctor strange 2 trailer
and click here to learn about all the x-men
and fantastic four easter eggs in the trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!